what is the satanic trinity
and what is its purpose
the satanic trinity is a reference to three
entities that combine to oppose the people of god
they are introduced to us in revelation 12 and
revelation 13. now before we get into revelation
12 and 13 let me tell you something about the
devil the devil likes to copy the techniques
of god god uses agents in the doing of his
business christ is an agent of god the church
is an agent of god individuals are agents of god
nature is an agent of god i should say creation
god uses agents well the devil does the same thing
we see that very clearly in the garden of eden
he used his agent the serpent having successfully
used that agent he then used eve as the second
agent and through her instrumentality he got adam
to fall satan uses agents as god uses agents now
keeping this in mind god requires worship satan
also wants worship that was the third temptation
he presented to jesus christ and so the devil
copies the techniques of god in acts chapter
2 verse 1 the bible says and when the day of
pentecost was fully come they were all with one
accord and in one place when stephen was stoned
in acts chapter 7 they were all with one accord
installing stephen because unity is strength and
so i say again for emphasis satan copies mimics
the techniques of god now having said that we
as bible believers we know there's the father
son the holy spirit satan has his satanic trinity
now let's go to revelation 12 and revelation 13.
now i didn't get a chance to pray so let me pray
now before i go any further father in heaven
put your words in my mouth i pray remember
the promise of exodus 4 12 which you made
to moses now therefore go and i will be with thy
mouth and teach you what thou shalt say do that
for me now i pray in jesus name amen
in revelation 12 we read from verse 1
and they appeared a great wonder in heaven a woman
clothed with the sun and the moon under her feet
and upon her head a crown of twelve stars and
she being with child cry prevailing in birth
and pain to be delivered at the first level
of interpretation that's mary who was heavily
pregnant with christ at a higher level it is the
church of god that was persecuted by this dragon
which now comes in in verse three and they
appeared another wonder in heaven and behold a
great red dragon having seven horns seven heads
and ten horns and seven crowns upon his heads
and he still drew the third part of the stars
in heaven and it cast him to the earth and the
dragon stood before the woman which was ready to
be delivered for to devour her child as soon as
it was born and so we're introduced to hostility
between the dragon and the woman in verse 7 now
john takes us way back into a far
distant past to explain the hostility
he describes in verses 3 to 5 of revelation 12.
so we have the woman then we have she's opposed by
the dragon now in verse 17 the dragon made
efforts to corrupt the work of the woman he
did not succeed in verse 17 of revelation 12 the
bible says and the dragon was wrath with the woman
and went to make war with the remnant of her
seed which keep the commandments of god and have
the testimony of jesus christ listen to verse 17
carefully the dragon was wroth with the woman he
was angry and went to make war with the remnant of
her seed the last part of the woman's descendants
the the last remaining portion the remnant that's
those living in these last days in a very special
way and the last days of course began in 1798
according to prophecy that's the last times
the last days began prophetically in 1798. now
the dragon went to make war with this remnant
now here is how he does that war we end revelation
12 in verse 17 he went to make war now in chapter
13 verse 1 were introduced to one of his agents
revelation 13 verse 1 and i stood up on the sand
of the sea and saw a beast rise up out of the
sea having seven heads and ten horns and upon
his horns ten crowns and upon his heads the name
of blasphemy and the beast which i saw was like
under a leopard and his feet was the feet of
a bear and his mouth as the mouth of a lion
and the dragon gave him his power and his
seat and great authority now here we have
the other entity which is what is called the
leopard-like beast it is also the man of sin
it is also the uh the antichrist it is also the
little horn all those terms apply to the same
entity which john saw coming up out of the sea
this is one of the agents that the devil uses
excuse me to wait war against the remnant of the
woman that part of the woman's descendants living
in the last days the other entity comes up in
verse 11 and i beheld another beast coming up
out of the earth and he had two horns like a lamb
and he spake as a dragon and he exerciseth all the
power of the first beast before him now so we have
the dragon in revelation 12 we have the leopard
like this or the man of sin or the little heart
or the antichrist or the son of perdition all of
those terms apply to this power in revelation 13
1-10 the third one is the beast in revelation 13
11-18 these three are make up the satanic trinity
satan is the head he may be regarded as the
satanic father because he gives power to those two
entities if you read verse 4 of revelation 13 and
they worship the dragon which gave power unto the
beast but verse 12 tells us of the other beasts
that came up from the earth he exercises all the
power of the first beast before him so the power
the beast of verse 1 to 10 of revelation 13 has
is the same power the beast of verses 11-18 has
the power is given to them by the dragon
who represents satan and so we have satan
the leopard-like beast and the two horned
beasts those three make up the satanic trinity
and their this their purpose is to destroy the
remnant of the seed of the woman and to sabotage
the work of the gospel that has been commissioned
to the remnant of the woman's sea that is
the satanic trinity in some kind of a nutshell
satan trying to mimic the powers of heaven
amen amen thank you for really breaking that down
elder scheme even starting from revelation chapter
12 the church of god and the fact that the enemy
is set out his ultimate design is to keep us from
connecting to god to keep us from the kingdom to
destroy us that's right we do not have salvation
we also have to note that the enemy is a master
con artist yes he is by deception so he copies god
changes a few things so that he can distract
us from the truth and i believe that's one
of the reasons in matthew 24 that jesus three
different times said take heed that you're not
deceived he says prophets are coming will come in
my name people will say i am christ they're low
he is there this is the methodology of
the enemy dragon the devil himself the
leopard like beast and the false prophet that's
right in revelation 11 revelation 13 verse 11
work together to destroy god's people and note
as elder skeet said this is the remnant the last
the people god's people in the last moments of
earth's history so the war is waging right now
even for our lives and the question is on whose
side are we standing and the issue of worship
because if you look at revelation 13 in verse 4
the bible says and they worship the the dragon
which gave power unto the beast and they worshiped
the beast now the beast of course is a religious
system worship is is suggests that this beast is a
religious system and so people ignorantly worship
this beast but the beast got the power from the
dragon so consequently by worshiping the beasts
of following the beast you are ultimately
following statement because the power of the beast
is the power of satan if you bow before an idol
you're actually bowing before satan this needs
to be understood and so the issue is worship in
verse 8 of revelation 13 and all that develop in
the earth shall worship him meaning the beast but
in worshiping the beast ultimately the worship is
directed to satan and since he deceiveth the whole
world revelation 12 9 without knowing it most of
the world regardless of the religious behavior
are actually worshiping the devil and they need to
be given the light of truth that their eyes may
be open that they may switch their allegiance
from the enemy to the savior jesus christ amen
amen elders keep you know that goes to show that
not only is war being waged against us but we also
have a work to do yes yes god's people should be
taking the gospel of the kingdom to all the world
for a witness in fact jesus is not going to come
unless we give that trumpet a certain sound
and it's important for us while satan is
you know parading the counterfeit of god's system
of worship that we uphold god's standard of truth
amen amen so thank you so much elder skeet we have
identified the satanic trinity and their purpose
namely the dragon which is the devil the
leopard-like beast and also the beast of
revelation 13 11 the false prophet um which comes
up out of the earth and eventually makes an image
to the beast so let's hold let's be bold we said
the dragon is the devil well let's identify the
other two that was the next question okay the
beast of revelation 13 1-10 is the people system
and the beast of revelation 13 1 11 to 18 is
the united states those are the three entities
and we know from prophecy that the beast
and his functioning will be replicated by
something called the image of the beast which
will be promoted by the united states which
is symbolized by the beast of revelation 13 11
through 18. and so we identify them not to cause
negative feelings but to open people's eyes you
see the devil's most powerful agent is a religious
system why do i say that it is not so much the
beast of revelation 13 11 to 18 but the one of
thirteen one to ten why listen again to revelation
13 1-2 and i stood upon the sand of the sea
and saw a beast rise up out of the sea having
seven heads and ten horns and open his horns ten
crowns and open his heads the name of blasphemy
and the beast which i saw was like unto a leopard
and his feet was the feet of a bear and his mouth
as the mouth of a lion what we have is an animal
that incorporates all the qualities of the four
kingdoms of daniel 7 the kingdom of babylon needle
persia greece and iran all of which contributed to
the persecution of god's people to various degrees
of severity and so this single entity combines all
you see babylon was just babylon mediocre was just
made of persian greece just greece wrong just
rome this unusual beast is a combination of all
and so it is the most deadly weapon the devil
can wield and it is a religious system which
means that attending church means very little to
the devil or to god unless you were in the right
system with thus saith the lord is
preached because satan his master stroke
is to use a religious system to preach error no
one expects ever from a pulpit but that's exactly
what the devil does all right amen thank you all
the skeet for ants for delineating that that the
leopard-like beast represents the people system
and the united states of america the false prophet
and we're going to be talking about the image of
the beast and what exactly that is as well but i
just want to underscore what elder skeet said the
fact that coming to church or any system going to
church is not enough to keep us from deception
in fact if we take a look at 2 thessalonians
chapter 2 verses 3 and 4 paul is speaking speaking
about the man of sin and we know the man of sin
correlates to that um leopard like beast here's
what paul says let no man deceive you by any means
for that day shall not come except there come a
falling away first what is that of falling away
from the truth and that sin be revealed the son
of perdition and watch verse four who opposes
and exalteth himself above all that is called god
or that is worshipped remember elvis keeps said
it's all about worship so that he as god sits in
the temple of god showing himself that he is god
so when the devil comes he's not going
to say i'm the devil he's going to say
i'm trying he's going to exactly okay and we
know that one of the titles of the pope is
uh god's representative he takes the place of
god on earth that is mentioned numerous times
in the writings of the church he takes the place
of god on earth there is no forgiveness of sins
but you can't go around the pope to be forgiven
not a church you see so yes that this this beast
takes or assume or tries to take the place of
god but that does not work for those who know
what the bible teaches but the deception is very
very powerful yes yes in fact one of the titles is
by um vicar a speaker of christ so in the place of
christ i believe on the trip on the pope's triple
crown in uh the vatican it has the inscription
philly i die biker of god have mercy all right so
just to make it clear elder skeet yes he spoke
about certain symbols like a dragon beast um the
beast that comes out of the earth that has two
horns like a lamb but speaks as a dragon but let's
just define what these symbols are prophetically
so what does represent in bible prophecy and uh
a beast represents a kingdom
in daniel chapter seven
uh daniel sees four beasts in verse four because
he's a lion verse five a bear six a leopard seven
8 this non-descript beast in verse 17 these four
these beasts which are four are four kings which
shall arise under the earth and so a king means
represents the very kingdom of variation so beasts
are kings or kingdoms verse 23 of daniel 7 thus he
said the fourth beast shall be the first kingdom
upon earth and shall be divers for all kingdoms
and shall divide the horror earth and tread it
down and break it in pieces and the ten horns
out of this kingdom are ten kings of salaries
now beasts therefore represent kingdoms horns
represent kingdoms as well a horn can represent
the head of that kingdom or the kingdom itself as
in the case of alexander he was the notable horn
in daniel 8 which was broken into two of course of
daniel 7 the greece is a leopard with four heads
meaning the same thing and so a beast is
a kingdom a horn is a kingdom or a person
representing that kingdom amen a throne simply
represents rulership the throne represents
rulership and i think the list also has water or
the sea the sea represents multitudes of people
revelation 17 verse 15 and he saith unto me
the waters which now sees where the whole city
are peoples and multitudes and nations and
towns and so seas represent multitudes of people
the earth now you've got to be careful with the
earth the earth can represent a barren place very
sparsely populated or the earth can seem to be the
earth itself because in revelation 12 12 the bible
says therefore rejoicing heavens and he that dwell
in them war to the inhabitants of the earth and
of the sea for the devil has come down unto you
having great wrath because he knows that he has
put a short time in that verse it literally means
the earth which is the the so-called property
of the devil because he overthrew adam but of
course through his resurrection and sacrifice
christ legally brought it back and so the earth
in revelation 12 12 literally means the earth
but when we read revelation 13 verse 11 and i saw
another and i beheld not a beast coming up out of
the earth it means a place with very few people
living in opposition to the seas which represent
teeming populations beautiful
beautiful thank you so much elder skeet
thank you so much for that there's one other
well you spoke about the throne but what about
crowns what do crowns represent because we see
that the beast yes [ __ ] you know we will reign
with christ uh revelation 5 verse 9 revelation 21
22 5 we shall reign with christ revelation 20 also
tells us we shall reign with christ of course
ii timothy chapter 4 verse 8 we shall receive a
crown jesus christ a crown is put on the head
of a ruler we shall reign with christ crowns
so we've defined some symbols where the beast
represents a kingdom where horns represent
kings sea right multitudes of people
the earth literal earth which christ has
reclaimed from the enemy but it can also represent
a place sparsely populated which is in contrast
and that's right that's right we have also
defined that crowns represent rulership and holy
power amen we've also defined the satanic trinity
and their purpose which is to destroy god's people
where the dragon is the devil where the
leopard-like beast is the papacy and the
false prophet represents the united states of
america and i know we kind of breeze through
breathe through that but friends i encourage
you to study on your own how we are able to
identify the united states of america with uh
the beast of revelation 13 11 the papacy with
the leopard-like beast the dragon well the
bible plainly says it in revelation verse 9.
but hopefully we'll also if god permits do a
session really breaking down the historical aspect
to this prophecy now if you are you just said the
bible clearly identifies the devil because that
is where the problem really lies the others are
merely agents of the devil and so the devil is
unmasked clearly and plainly revelation 12 9 the
dragon is is is a serpent revelation 21st 2 he is
plainly exposed because he is the problem he is
the power behind the beast of revelation 13 1-10
the beast of revelation 13 11 through
18 and so he is identified and then we
now have to use our minds um to
figure out who the other two are
and with just a small effort guided by the spirit
we come to the conclusions of course we talk about
the roman system and united states but the devil
is clearly identified because he is the problem
amen amen in fact indeed the devil is the problem
and note how we are saying the roman system that
doesn't mean that roman catholics are outside
of god's way to bring in or someone that is
not quote-unquote seventh-day adventists has no
opportunity to accept the gospel the issue is with
the system of worship that work yes that works
by deception to lead god's people astray even
as the serpent in the garden of eden worked upon
eve who prophetically would represent a church
and deceive her and here we are today let me say
this about a system and it's not very pleasant
when christ was crucified the church
worked with the system to crucify christ
in these last days we have to be careful that
god's remnant people do not cooperate with the
satanic system by the choices we make and the
way we interpret the bible or the way we try to
to reduce the severity of some of our teachings
severity is a bad word but weaken the strength
of some of our teaching you know there's a
movement to stop saying the remnant church of god
uh don't emphasize the sabbath don't emphasize the
ten commandments these kinds of actions have us
cooperating with the system and so as the system
found help from the church of god in in the days
of christ when he was crucified because pilate
wanted to let jesus go their church said crucify
him and i say the church because the church was
represented by the leaders in these last days
as we're up against the most powerful instrument
the devil has ever used the beast of revelation
13 1-10 we must be careful in our preaching our
teaching the way we function all our institutions
our churches our schools our hospitals that we do
not cooperate with the system represented by the
beast of revelation 13 1-10 we have to be very
careful we don't help the devil to do his work
amen amen you so much eldeskey
charge for that charge
you